the corona virus pandemic is hitting
farmers hard some dairy farmers are
being forced to dump their milk instead
of selling it because there's little
demand with restaurants and schools
closed other farmers are struggling to
harvest their crops which could affect
what you'll see at the grocery store
foreign labor mostly migrant workers
filled more than a quarter million jobs
in the US last year as mark Strassmann
reports harvest season is here but there
are not enough workers you're looking at
one of Georgia's biggest farms 7,000
acres more than a dozen crops that help
feed America in this cabbage field we
found farmer Bill brim walking with his
worries this coronavirus has got
everybody so stirred up does it keep you
up at night oh yeah I sleep about two
and a half three hours a night seasonal
foreign labor mainly from Mexico always
harvest brims crops but this spring he
could be 200 workers short the
coronavirus crisis has delayed the US
government's processing of their work
visas bill brims facing a series of
harvest deadlines first one is April
15th and these fields of squash May
first it's cucumbers and so on and he'd
better have his pickers in place when we
start harvesting squash we've got just
days to pick it so if our workers don't
show up here on time then we're gonna be
in real trouble it's not one of those
things in life we can say I get to it
next week no no no no sir I wish we
could
70 miles away Jeremy white is in bigger
trouble his blueberry crop is days away
from harvest he needs 100 pickers and
Packers but they're stuck in Guatemala
where the borders are sealed because of
the virus nobody in nobody out we need
them now absolutely we need them now as
you can see this fruits turning blue and
it's not waiting on anybody more than a
million dollars worth of blueberries
could rot in the fields he has no plan B
domestic labor just don't want to do
this kind of work I'm out that's
unfortunate to say but I mean I you know
they just don't want to get out and do
her
field labor anymore Gary black is
Georgia's Commissioner of Agriculture it
is a reality if there are not workers no
big crops it will go unharvested and
that has a ripple effect throughout this
economy and it will affect the consumers
this nation bill brims worries go beyond
his labor shortage what if the workers
he does have get sick and restaurants
usually buy 60 percent of his crops not
this year not with so many restaurants
closed this big farm how much money
could it lose if this doesn't turn
around it could devastate us he could
put us out of business really 35 years
you've owned it right and this could be
it
that's right to be hope not we hope and
pray or not you know we hoping this
coronavirus will get out of here and and
we can go back just a little bit of
normalcy timing is now everything here
these crops can't wait for CBS this
morning
mark Strassmann Tifton Georgia